did you know up until that point that
you would try to make your living as a
writer or
this opportunity just presented itself i
had thought about
seriously pursuing writing before that
first opportunity came up
and so i'd been studying it i'd always
been interested in it so i'd always been
reading
and reading screenplays reading books
about screenwriting
but more as just part of a larger
filmmaking
curriculum i didn't know necessarily
what i wanted to do
but it was probably in the few months
leading up to that that i thought maybe
writing is actually where
i i really want to focus where i'm most
fulfilled where i'm
decent at it and
i had perhaps just kind of been more
vocal about that at
where i was working and that's probably
why this job came up
and i was considered to write it
and so i think it was i thought about it
before writing
that project and i think writing that
project really solidified okay this is
what
i want to do and probably at that point
it got in my head that
i should move out to la if i'm going to
get serious about this
you grew up in north carolina correct
yeah
at what point did you say you would move
to la so you're living in georgia you
get this great opportunity
it sounds like the perfect thing for
someone as a
first-time screenwriting project yeah it
was great i think
from that point it was about six months
to when i left atlanta
but i wasn't actually sure where i was
going to go
because my girlfriend was also looking
for
a move to get more serious about her
profession in
performance and writing but we didn't
know where a good fit for both of us
would be so we saved up
tons of money and we actually took about
a five month
road trip and we checked out new york we
were there for about a month my sister
lived there at the time and so we stayed
with her for a month we went to chicago
stayed with my aunt
went to l.a didn't know anyone saw a
couple
airbnbs and some some motel rentals
but basically we wanted to park in those
cities for a couple weeks so that
we could see what it would be like to
live there beyond just visiting
both as the city how we liked it and
also professionally like
what was going on and after doing the
three of them
pretty quickly la became the clear
choice
and so then we drove back to georgia
picked up all of our stuff out of a
storage unit and then
trucked it all the way back out west
that's really interesting so instead of
doing a road trip documentary
or something you just did your life was
this road trip and then
you sort of based on where you wanted to
land so to speak
yeah we checked out we went to tons of
screenings tons of theaters in
all those cities tried to go to as many
meetups as possible set up as many
meetings just over coffee with whoever
we could
just to get a sense of the community
and the industry within those cities and
where we would have the best shot
at starting off and
la was the choice that became apparent
especially for me
as a feature writer and
then once we saw the theater scene in la
it worked out for my girlfriend as well
where was the first place you you drove
to like
when you when you got off the five or
whatever 101
where was the first place you
destination um
the first place we stopped was west
hollywood i had a friend
it was actually my mom's best friend's
son who had met a few times
and i asked him if we could crash on his
couch for a bit
and he let us as
way longer than we had we told him we
probably would be
be there but right in west hollywood
wow how was the parking it was tough
that's the thing you'd a lot of people i
don't think think about you know
yeah the parking is such an issue yeah
many places
in my budget i allow like at least two
tickets a year i just said
i just figure it's got i'll mess up
somewhere
so you go back to georgia you get your
stuff you come here
to la was it more difficult than you had
initially imagined
it was not more difficult than i had
imagined
moving to la but it was difficult
i saved up and i was ready to
dig in and i'd hoped
that maybe i would had been over
prepared
but i felt like i was prepared and it
was tough especially that first year
and it's not that i didn't have
successes that first year it's that it
was way more kind of
up up and down it was higher highs and
lower lows that first year
of not just screenwriting but even just
living
in a new city a big city an expensive
city
and so i got here
immediately started looking for
part-time work just wherever i could get
it
started looking for internships wherever
i could i ended up with
three internships at one point
i was going into i was assisting at a
talent agency
two days a week i was remotely reading
scripts for a production company and
then as soon as that one ended i got
into
reading scripts for a management company
here in la
and so it's really busy all of course
unpaid so i'm doing my part-time work as
well
and i'm trying to write my own material
at the same time and so
it was a real grind at first and
the second year got easier but
just as the there weren't as many lower
lows or higher highs but it was still
that little bit of a grind and i think i
let the pedal off a little bit i thought
i had kind of
oh i figured this out and i think
ellie started pushing back a little bit
as well
and i felt it and so now after
three just about three whole years here
i feel like okay i think i figured out
at least how to live here now let's
figure out how to screen right here
oh wow that's interesting okay what was
the most
difficult thing to get used to in terms
of living in la and
then also what's the most difficult in
terms of looking for screenwriting work
in terms of living in la the most
difficult thing for me was definitely
the traffic and the
timing of things i am a
planner so i'm always i definitely want
to be there on time
for whatever meaning whatever thing i
have going on and
not only was i holding myself for that
standard but also other people so i
the traffic i knew would be really bad
and so i would leave excessively early
and i'd get to a coffee meeting for
someone to
to meet with or a project or another
writer to ask for advice
and i would be upset when they were late
even if it was like five or ten minutes
late like
irrationally upset and so it was a
difficult learning curve for me to sort
of learn to let that
go and just people are going to be
either really late or really early
because traffic is just so
erratic here and you can never tell
where it's going to be backed up
and for how long so once i started just
getting in the habit of making sure that
i always had
a new book on my kindle or my phone or
something i always had something to do
and something to work on
it got a lot easier for me to sort of
hang out and wait for people to meet
and also i realized how great people
were
about when i was running late how they
were just they were cool with it i was
like well i need to learn how to be cool
about it too
yeah i remember for me coming here as
well that was a lesson someone had to
sit me down and
talk to me about because i would hold
myself to that standard and i would beat
myself up if i was like five minutes
late
and then the same for someone else and
so i
that was a tough one for me as well yeah
yeah because because i think if you're
conscientious
when someone else isn't it's like you're
like whoa you know
i think that that was a tough one for me
yeah well i would feel
i would feel terrible if i was running
late and
then when i would finally get there the
other person would just
be like yeah no big deal traffic i was
like oh
i need to learn how to be like that i
mean i need to be as cool
about it as you are when you're the one
running late right that's
because you know i felt taken care of
and
i wanted to make sure that i was taking
care of people too and they
ran into traffic sure and then there's
just people that are chronically late
all the time
they just use that as an excuse but well
the great thing about la is that it's
the permanent excuse you can just always
just say
traffic right yeah exactly and it's a
great time to
to give yourself time to do something if
you're super early for things because
sometimes you'll you'll
surprise yourself and you'll be like 45
minutes early for something i'm assuming
i'm sorry
yeah that happens to me too and and then
you're just sitting there and you have
all this time
and you can do other things well what i
started doing is when i would
anytime i'd have a meeting i would just
go there hours early and then i would
just work
if i had the time i would just get there
super early so i don't have to worry
about it and now all that time between
when i would
drive and meeting someone i would just
work there instead of working at home or
a coffee shop i would just go work at a
coffee shop i was about to meet them at
that way i'm just there
and i can literally just work right up
until whenever they show up whether
they're early late right on time
i can get my work done so it sounds like
the most difficult part of
just the living arrangements in la is
the traffic and wanting to be on time
for people and that's understandable
that's commendable
what about the most difficult time in
getting acclimated
to finding screenwriting work
um because there's also a looseness
the way things are done here too in
terms of yeah and everyone's nice and
i never hear from you yeah um
i don't know if i'm actually if i'm
really like sort of qualified to answer
that question i feel like i'm still
trying to figure out how to get
screenwriting work
i feel like the screenwriting work i've
gotten
is mostly through
friends or friends of friends i have yet
to figure out how to just
secure that job find that job get it and
start working both of the
jobs i've had since i've moved here it
was not
planned to be a job it was a friend
saying hey i have a friend out in la who
actually directs films you guys should
grab coffee just to catch up
um see what they're up to and we have
coffee we
end up talking and then a few days later
i get the call hey would you actually
want to write
my screenplay but there was never any
sort of oh i'm going in to pitch on this
thing
or i'm going to meet with this director
because he's looking for a screenwriter
there was never any of that in any of
the jobs i've ever
gotten so i guess i'd say the most
difficult thing is figuring that out
that you won't necessarily know how your
jobs are going to come to you and
being okay with that and going to
meet people and hang out with people and
talk to people with no sense of a job on
the other end
but recognize that just through meeting
people you're gonna have more
opportunities
even if you don't necessarily know what
they are that was another conversation
someone had with me too just the
looseness of in terms of
you could nev you might yeah we should
totally connect
never hear from them and then you hear
from them like a year later and then
they have something great for you
and you were like wow they never even
returned my call that's so weird i
thought okay
i'll take it you know yeah but that's
another thing too it's like
there's not really a lot of rules and
there's no hard yes or no
yeah i think that the way this industry
works it could be that
one year ago i met someone who's going
to change my life next year
and i have no clue who that person is
but i could get a call from someone i
met
at a mixer or some sort of table read
something
and say hey that thing you said about
that project you were working on
i really dug that and my buddy is
actually doing something similar
you should talk to him and then that
ends up being a job but i have no clue
that that thing i did a year ago is
going to pay off a year from now
because that's just how it works and
it's really tough to calculate
so i think if anything i've learned just
to not
try and calculate yeah
nothing's definite yeah and that's a
hard especially if
you're a planner and i get that and i'm
you can fall into the same
way that that you like things to be
boxes to be checked off and so yeah
that's that's another one that's
interesting there's nothing definite no
hard yes or no
you